A long time ago in a galaxy far, far away,
George Lucas created Star Wars: A New Hope,
spawning an entire franchise of awesomeness.
Decades later, we're still learning all kinds
of secrets from behind the scenes.
Stabilize your rear deflectors as we scan
the Star Wars saga for some stuff even the
Jedi Council didn't know.
Number one: IG-88 on tap
As part of the group of bounty hunters hired
by Darth Vader to find the Millennium Falcon
in Empire Strikes Back, IG-88 looked really
intimidating… but at the same time, he looked
really familiar.
That's because he was previously seen in A
New Hope, in one of the least likely of places:
as a Mos Eisley Cantina drink dispenser.
That's right, the same prop pieces used to
create IG-88's head are also scattered behind
the cantina's bar.
R2-D2 and C-3PO were just steps away from
becoming a couple of bickering distilleries.
But IG-88 isn’t the only one with an unlucky
head...
Number two: Jango hits his head
We've all seen the Star Wars blooper of the
Stormtrooper accidentally walking into a door
in A New Hope.
George Lucas even went back to add a sound
effect to the mishap during the DVD re-release
of the original trilogy.
But did you know that Lucas paid homage to
this blooper in Attack of the Clones?
After the fight between Jango Fett and Obi-Wan
Kenobi, the bounty hunter can be seen fleeing
to the Slave I as a young Boba Fett is firing
up its engines.
During Jango's hasty retreat, you can see
the ship's door clipping his helmet as he
passes, accompanied by an appropriate sound
effect.
Some argue that Jango didn't actually hit
his head during this blink-and-you-miss-it
moment, but we'd imagine that Lucas would've
closed the door normally if he meant otherwise.
Now we know where that Stormtrooper inherited
his clumsiness.
It’s certainly not the worst thing that
happened to Jango’s head, though.
Number three: Marvel gives Star Wars a hand
Phase Two of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is filled with tributes to The Empire Strikes
Back.
Specifically, every movie in Phase Two includes
a scene of a character losing an arm, Skywalker-style.
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige said
to CinemaBlend, "I’m obsessed with Star
Wars.
It didn’t start out as intentional, but
it became intentional."
Number four: Those darn helmets
"I can't see a thing in this helmet!"
You think that explains why the Stormtroopers
are all bad shots?
Well, that wasn't exactly in the script.
In this scene, Mark Hamill was complaining
to Harrison Ford after he thought the cameras
had stopped rolling.
Surprisingly, Lucas decided to keep the line
in the movie.
Just be happy you weren't wearing that Darth
Vader mask, Luke.
Number five: The Force Awakens gets Raided
We've all seen the awesome cameos packed into
The Force Awakens, but there are a lot more
than you may realize, including appearances
by Bill Hader, Simon Pegg, Ken Leung, Warwick
Davis, and James Bond himself, Daniel Craig.
For those wondering, Craig played the Stormtrooper
who was Jedi mind tricked by Rey into setting
her free.
There are a ton of Game of Thrones cameos
as well.
We all know Brienne of Tarth actress Gwendoline
Christie plays Captain Phasma, but there are
plenty of other cameos brought in from the
Seven Kingdoms.
Thomas Brodie Sangster, Jessica Henwick, Mark
Stanley, Miltos Yerolemou, and Emun Elliott
also appear in small roles throughout the
film.
Our favorite Force Awakens cameo comes in
the form of the criminal gang, Kanjiklub.
Fans of the Indonesian action flicks The Raid:
Redemption and The Raid 2 should recognize
Yayan Ruhian, Iko Uwais, and Cecep Arif Rahman.
That's Rama and two of his fiercest opponents
from the franchise!
Number six: Starkiller vs. Skywalker
Dedicated Star Wars fans know that George
Lucas originally intended for the protagonist
of his series to have the last name of "Starkiller."
Of course, Starkiller sounds a bit darker
than Skywalker, so the name was changed.
Eventually, LucasArts could use the Starkiller
name for the protagonist in Star Wars: The
Force Unleashed.
This video game puts you in the jackboots
of Darth Vader's secret apprentice, ordered
to create a small rebellion against the Empire
to distract the Emperor enough to be overthrown.
These events actually led to the creation
of the Rebel Alliance.
Unfortunately, most of the lore outside of
the movies and recent TV series got thrown
into the Sarlacc Pit once Disney took control
of the series.
At least J.J.
Abrams brought the Starkiller name back for
the new Death Star.
We know, it's technically not a Death Star,
but actually a mobile ice planet superweapon.
It's still just a really, really big Death
Star that can blast multiple planets at once
from across the solar system.
Big difference.
Number seven: Where credit is due
We all love the iconic "A long time ago in
a galaxy far, far away…" scroll before each
Star Wars film, but did you ever notice that
there are no opening credits before any of
the movies in the series?
The Directors Guild of America slapped George
Lucas with a hefty $250,000 fine for not properly
crediting the director before the film, even
though he wasn't the first person to do this.
As a result, Lucas severed ties with the guild
like it was a Skywalker's arm.
Youch!
Number eight: Jedi Master Tupac
Yes, you read that right, and no, we're not
making this up.
Rolling Stone reports the late, great Tupac
Shakur auditioned to star as Mace Windu in
The Phantom Menace.
Details are a bit shaky, since Tupac was murdered
in September of 1996 and filming on Episode
I started nine months later.
Nevertheless, just imagine if "Thug Life"
himself was cast as Mace Windu.
Tupac could have tossed aside his beef with
the East Coast's rappers and started feuding
with the Sith instead.
While some diehard rap fans believe Tupac
may still be alive and in hiding, there’s
no way that Mace Windu survived that brutal
electrocution and defenestration.
Number nine: The rasp of Leia
Did you ever watch Return of the Jedi and
wonder why this voice sounds familiar?
(Star Wars alien voice speaking)
Surprisingly, that voice was done by the late
actress Pat Welsh.
While her list of film credits is short, you
might recognize her for one other prominent
role: E.T.
the Extra-Terrestrial.
The voice of that adorable, beer-chugging,
candy-eating alien is the same as the bounty
hunter disguise Leia used when threatening
to suicide bomb Jabba's palace with a thermal
detonator.
Still, as some fans may know, this isn't the
only connection between ET and the Star Wars
saga...
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
obscure Star Wars fact surprised you the most...